and this is from ham hunt so somebody
went to an art exhibit in Miami where
there was this Basel thing yeah there
was a banana duct taped to a wall and it
was priced to be sold for a hundred and
twenty the first the first installation
was purchased and then another one was
purchased both by French people the
third one was the one who that was set
in the museum this guy came up there
said that he was doing a performance art
piece by taking the banana off of the
wall peeling it and then eating 120
grand for it it didn't have to be this
big a hutch also also that that's that's
that's the price tag on that stupid
piece of [ __ ] Yan art it's not art
because well it's gonna it's not gonna
laugh this is what the art piece is the
banana and the tape isn't the art piece
the art piece is the concept of having a
banana duct tape - so how do you of
course I'll set up with ten of them in
here yeah it's you're selling a concept
yeah this is my son run out of ideas
oh there's Dove and I went to a modern
era place and they had the they didn't
have any art the artist put a what you
would put the art on the mountain the
frame the but the flooring it was just
metal on the floor and that was those
they are yeah and he's a famous artist
Jesus in the modern art what's on
probably so he was so radical that he is
oh there be no art this is just the the
dirty piece of metal that I mean it's so
great when I love that these morons
spend that much money on non art on its
and it's non art modern our most modern
art is all fraud it's all horseshit and
the only reason it's expensive is
because a small group of people with
money not only say it's worth that but
also brokers yeah they said brokers will
say the price yeah horseshit you want to
watch the clip sure this dumbass in a
minute I hate when they that he did that
to you
you see us some chicks around she said
this is stupid huh she works for the
museum is she saying this so stupid why
are you eating it yeah
and this third installation was actually
priced at 150 grand yes should be a
banana
yep great was just some billionaires and
this is all this tension this is like
he's not gonna pay this market would
never stand up in court
yeah it kind of made him [ __ ] up he
[ __ ] it up and now them hmm don't they
could try to sue him or something but
they won't what are the odds that they
did this as a plan the artist and him
yeah I can see that that's like banks t
selling his real art mm-hmm for like $6
um do you see that yeah he had a bunch
of his real bro didn't like those third
sheep it's on that it's not a straight
he's selling over like you know someone
gives once hits the jab yeah but then
they just sell it to tone that he didn't
want getting old of it so it works
although his a lot of his art didn't
sell like they had a lot of his art the
broker and the Hamptons had his art
there and so far none of the pieces of
sold and they're all on there for 300
grand for a grant and they haven't sold
cuz you know when a push comes to shove
I don't count much money you have you're
like that's a lot of money for that you
know three I know I bet for bankage it's
pretty cool I love his stuff some art is
incredible a high school yeah if I had
the money I'd have my house to be full
of really great yeah me too I love great
art to tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]